alors on va imaginer laurent etc et que
vous appeliez tout ce que vous mettez en
cause dans votre livre et que vous leur
laissez un message en livre après vous
servir devant lille oui on va faire
l'interview messagerie
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes sur la messagerie de
josé bové vous pouvez laisser un message
c'est à vous à l'eau josé j'espère que
tu vas bien mais il faudrait vraiment
que tu te rases les moustaches parce que
franchement ils sont jaunes elles sont
en forme de m à chaque fois tu vois ta
gueule j'ai envie d'aller bouffer chez
mcdo
bonjour j'ai sur le répondeur de carole
rousseau j'ai une idée d'émission pour
vous ça s'appellerait scrupules c'est à
dire ce serait encore pire que scrupules
et j'ai même le générique de l'émission
se serait on va tomber encore plus bas
c'est la faute à voltaire on va tomber
dans le ruisseau c'est la faute à
rousseau
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes sur le répondeur de bernadette
chirac fois laissé un message à l'eau
bernadette excuse a bien reçu votre
brumisateur
vous êtes sur le programme de michael
jackson pourrait laisser un message
à l'aube orbi déjà beaucoup un peu
intime à l'aube orbi je sais pas il
paraît que tout et procèdent coûte la
peau des fesses alors qu'est ce qui va
te rester
[Musique]
ce
statut lui dire quand même c'est bizarre
parce qu'il s'appelle bambi et ses
lentilles pinocchio parce que plus
humain plus on est raccourci
[Musique]
vous êtes sur un corner de florent pagny
et je vous laisse un message à florent
pagny et écoute si tu passes à bercy
pense pas à penser au ministère des
finances c'est tout voilà
bonjour bien sur le répondeur de nicolas
sarkozy pour laisser votre message je
lui dirai nicolas arrête de te laisser
pousser les oreilles ça commence à
énerver son automne de chirac
bonjour j'ai sur le répondeur de janet
jackson peut laisser votre message janet
je t'ai vu montré un sein mtv awards 3
l'inter aux mtv awards arrête de faire
ces conneries là parce que jane birkin
va faire la même chose aux victoires
américaines
j'ai un écran plat alors je vais rien à
voir
bonjour j'ai lu sur le répondeur de
dieudonné bon spectacle parce que c'est
là où tu es le meilleur c'est sur scène
donc continuer à faire du spectacle un
peu moins de politique parce que
franchement
heureusement que c'est coluche qui a
ouvert les restos du coeur si ç'avait
été toi dieudo il y aurait eu d'à côté
les restos halal et de l'autre les
restos cacher
j'ai fait sur le répondeur je me dis que
je suis imposé ces passages salués naudy
donc à peine élu et déjà enfermé en
prison tu vas plus vite que les autres
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux